à l'intérieur de cette pâte visqueuse
verte il ya ça des milliards de
bactéries que les aztèques connaissait
déjà pour leurs vertus nutritives leur
richesse en oligo éléments et en sels
minéraux
il existe environ 150 petites fermes
aquacoles de ce type en france des
structures artisanales active durant
seulement quelques mois de l'année car
il faut de la lumière et de la chaleur
pour que la micro algues se développent
dans l'eau installé dans une ancienne
serre horticole
arnaud est lancé dans l'aventuré moi
c'est un début d'activité donc tout est
pas encore rodé enfin je suis parti avec
un bassin le deuxième jeu les ensemencer
ya à peu près un mois
et quand il y aura les trois bassins en
service genre à potentiel dans les 5 600
kg production annuelle de brindilles de
produits secs plusieurs semaines sont
nécessaires avant la récolte une
opération landes de filtrage puis une
succession d'interventions jusqu'à
obtenir un produit sec qui se consomme à
l'état pur
peu de ressemblance avec la production
industrielle ça c'est la spiruline
fraîche qu'on peut consommer comme ça
mais qui va se garder relativement peu
de temps par rapport à une spiruline
on va avoir en brindille donc c'est pour
ça qu'on va là déshydraté pour avoir un
poids du sac et pourra le garder nos
clients l'engouement pour le produit
encourage évidemment les installations
de sites de production
reste à savoir si cette algue tant
populaire a autant de vertus que cela
les études scientifiquement sur le sujet
seul sait qu'au tessin est hyper
nutritifs sont incontestables